so let's suppose you were dating a girl
for 10 years yeah okay and everyone
knows uh-huh like we're public yeah but
they were public too I know but just
hear me out okay
and 10 years and your friends
are liking her on Raya
wanting to date oh like my friends are
liking who you mean yeah you're right
we're matching on Raya yeah that would
be difficult it's not difficult don't
you think that that's a boundary that
they shouldn't cry I don't think you
should be friends with them
yeah I will and we'll bleep them all
right we'll [__] bleep them all right
he's been on our podcast once or twice
who are we talking about there's a
several oh my God
okay I met him a long time I did Jim
Norton's radio show with him like years
and years ago and I was like they were
like do you want to take a picture with
him I was like oh no it's all right and
they were like take a picture with him
and I was like and then he thought it
was like some Fanboy I was like I don't
give a [__] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah who and who any others
um who else oh what's
what's the the black guy's name
um
[Laughter]
[Music]
um he had his own talk show you're not
really friends with him but I started
with them I've known him for 20 years
yeah have him do the podcast
and confront him confront him right I
just find it to be weird Behavior that's
all but you know we don't like actually
match or talk or anything you see that
they like you yeah and then you don't
reply back
um yeah because Comics are just out of
my thank you and thank you for having
that boundary yeah I'll never date
another comic I don't think you don't
think so no never no it's not a it's
just not it's not smart what that what's
that like because I know your ex was
also like a comic Sarah as a stand-up
like what is the dynamic there when well
I think in your case you know you were
dating somebody that was like
at your level right sure the hard part
is when you're dating somebody that's
just started
right yeah imagine like never do that
yeah imagine somebody like I'm doing
open mics but you're like attracted to
them and you like them yeah you know at
one point it's gonna there's gonna be
lines that are cross and you're gonna be
like calling you know or giving them
advice or calling somebody for a gig or
you know I mean or you have to have them
open for you yeah that's I think that's
hard being both being Headliners is
important or both being lower is
important you know like if you're if one
of yeah the opening for the other person
sure it's nice you know but like it's
not it's not healthy it's not healthy to
have a power Dynamic like that like a I
don't think that's smart right but uh
yeah I would never do it again and not
that it wasn't good yeah you have good
times but I just think it's not uh no I
just think two headshots in a
relationship can be lead to trust
I think that's you know so um tell me
you want to promote your dates yeah uh
Birmingham Memphis Nashville uh Portland
Maine Mashantucket Connecticut I think
that's Mohegan Sun or Fox was I don't
even [__] remember uh lots of stuff
coming up uh I said Memphis right
Chattanooga Knoxville Denver uh Santa Fe
San Antonio Houston
uh all over the South and uh a ton of
stuff I can't remember all of it but a
ton of stuff coming up Sam you know I
hear things on the road and you know
getting people it was consensual okay no
I want to say a compliment I want to go
you're really On The Rise oh you're like
no I'm being real and um you're like the
future you and Mark and that generation
you guys are so good thank you and it
inspires me to write and it inspires me
to keep going
um it's just a pleasure to have you here
man dude I love it love seeing you love
doing this